we debate this morning with so the guy
from the youth forum representative of
the Parliament a representative of the
Commission representative of the council
and it was not so difficult to find the
winners winners of each category will go
to Oslo on the center tense joining the
delegation of European Union to receive
surprise in aa stroke this is the winner
the girl is a spanish girl of twelve
years old and her name is Anna fan lo be
sent a photo text the winner is an
Italian girl of 16 years old her name is
Elena Nicoletta gabacho piece is a
bridge with share it ends and for the
3rd cavalry the winner is a Polish girl
of twenty one-year-old and her name is
Ilona Z LVL Koshka peace in Europe is
like air it's a mixture which lets us
live it gives us a space to spread our
wings there is a fourth category which
is the price of the public which is
being chosen with a further contest on
facebook so basically any citizen of the
european union can go on facebook and
like the best basically the most voted
one will be coming as fourth